I am excited to share with you that the
rmx logic metagenomics program will be
starting October 29th in this online
program we will explore the amazing raw
microbes play in human wellbeing health
and disease designed to be equally
rewarding for students and researchers
the program will cover main aspects of
metagenomic sequencing analysis of 16s
ribosomal RNA and other aspects of
microbiology research that is using
violent Romantics at the end of the
program participants will be conducting
independent or group projects analyzing
data from public domain and learning
from high-impact biomedical publications
on the microbiome this program will
begin by reviewing the way Amish logic
series has helped thousands of students
around the world get a quick
introduction into the world of omics
data by learning about analysis logic in
the context of real research projects we
will talk about the online sessions
courses you can follow at your own pace
and supporting infrastructure we make
available to program participants that
want to conduct analysis of big
biomedical data we will also discuss
effective learning strategies that
maximize the impact of this two-month
program and will help you develop a set
of practical skills that will advance
your research project or career to learn
about metagenomics we will discuss what
the microbiome is how we can use
next-generation sequencing to study
whole microbial communities and analyze
individual microbial genomes we will
also discuss data sets that are
available for analysis and study of the
raw microbes play in agriculture
biomedical research and even
epidemiological studies of infectious
diseases to study microbial communities
over microbiomes
we will learn about 16s and 18s
ribosomal RNA and the way analysis of
hyper variable regions can yield
important information about the
microbiome composition good
understanding of the way data is
will allow us to navigate research
studies with ease and read library
preparation protocols mentioned in
common data repositories 16s amplicon
sequencing is a recently developed
technique that is widely used to study
microbiome directly in its environment
such metagenomic sequencing focuses on
16s or 18s ribosomal RNA that has to be
first amplified with PCR amplification
the 16s gene sequences contain
hypervariable regions that provide
species specific signature sequences
useful for bacterial identification
that's why we will learn about how 16s
amplicon sequencing is especially useful
but also challenging and we will learn
how to use it to study the microbial
communities and their impact on ecology
and human health we will review such
examples using datasets from studies
looking at the gut brain access where
diets are linked to behavioral changes
and projects that collect microbial
samples from people of different
backgrounds to understand how the human
microbiome is shaped by diet and even
ethnic background but the gut is not the
only microbial community we live with
specific microbiota exist with their
hosts in are vital for health we can use
metagenomic sequencing and measures like
alpha and beta diversity to study how
they vary from individual to individual
these studies offer important insights
into the way microbial communities
function and how the microbiome
composition is linked to host condition
analysis of metagenomic sequencing data
requires a thorough examination of
challenges with short read mapping
existing reference databases of 16s
hypervariable regions and various batch
effects that make some of the analysis
interpretation challenging we will
explore each one of these in detail and
see examples of methods that address
these difficulties we will also learn
about mapping on a reference database
like the green genes sylva ribosomal
database project or RDP and NCBI these
databases are curated to help
the metagenomic sequences in link
hypervariable regions to aid in
taxonomic classification as an example
of a full processing and analysis
pipeline we will utilize the data to
pipeline that combines various
pre-processing tools with
state-of-the-art annotation methods to
make metagenomic studies easy even for a
novice we will see several ways the
pipeline can be adapted to study alpha
and beta diversity as well as used to
understand abundance of various
taxonomies in a sample the visual
interface of the T balloon for platform
will enable users to quickly build
logical graphs of their analysis and
understand each step significance and
role in this pipeline for those
interested to implement the pipeline on
their own we will offer guidance and
references that can be used to
effectively install all the needed
packages for this pipeline as a result
we will gain a thorough understanding of
metagenomic analysis and get hands-on
experience with standard metagenomic
data types pipelines and outputs towards
the end of the project each participant
will be able to develop a project of
their own based on thousands of publicly
available datasets these projects will
be introduced using several examples
that combine amplicon metagenomic
sequencing and analysis of individual
microbial genomes bacteria and viruses
several examples we will review include
additional projects like the study of
microbial drug resistance
viral adaptation and rise of bacteria
analysis using genome-wide Association
methods like linear mixed models this
program is intended for anyone
interested in gaining practical hands-on
experience with metagenomics in the
deeper understanding of the microbes how
they evolved live together and adapt to
their hosts to register visit
edu T bio infocomm forward slash
metagenomics